I want to start with, I
guess for lack of a better
word, two vignettes. One,
and it really is lack of a
better word, vignette
is actually a series of,
of statistics. You don't
need to keep them from your
notes, but I want you to
understand them from an
impressionistic point of
view. These--this is a
tallying of the state of
segregation in 1951. It's a
random point in time in
the South. In May of 1951,
the state of Texas did not
allow interracial boxing
matches. Florida did
not allow white and black
students to use the same
editions of textbooks.
In Alabama, a white woman
was not allowed to take care
of a black male patient.
North Carolina required
separate washrooms in its
factories. South Carolina
required them in its cotton
mills. Four other states
required them
in their mines.
In six
states--and there's a,
I'm going to be reading a
list in numbers of states.
They're overlapping in
different combinations,
I'm quite
sure--in six states,
white and black prisoners
could not be chained
together.In
seven states, parks,
playgrounds, bathing
and fishing and boating
facilities, amusement
parks, race tracks,
pool halls, circuses,
theaters and public halls
were all segregated. Ten
states required separate
waiting rooms for bus and
train travelers. Fourteen
states required black
passengers to ride in the
back of buses and
streetcars. Some other
combination of fourteen
states segregated railroad
passengers on trips within
their borders. Some other
combination of
fourteen states required
mental--segregated mental
patients. Some seventeen
states required segregation
of public schools. Four
other states permitted
the practice if local
communities
wished it. And in,
and in Washington, D.C.,
the custom had prevailed for
nearly ninety
years. In eleven,
in eleven states--and
this one I find is actually
breathtaking for the
absurdity of all of this,
or maybe even the passion
for all of this--in eleven
states, eleven states
operated separate schools
for the blind. So even
if you could not see each
other, you could not be in
the same space if you were
white and if you were
black. It's a thoroughgoing
segregation across
many different lines,
many different vectors, of
how you operate as a citizen
in the world.
Now that's 1950,
'51.
I want to read to you an
excerpt from the memoir
Warriors Don't
Cry by Melba Beals,
who was one of the, who
would become one of the,
would become one of
the Little Rock Nine,
who'd deseg--desegregate
Central High School. We'll
be talking--I'll talk a
little bit about Central
High School in Monday's
lecture. We're actually
chronologically not getting
up to that point in today's
lecture. But I want to
read to you an excerpt from
1954--of events that
happened in 1954--to help
underscore, undergird the
extent to which the kind of
higher level organizing
and political work and legal
affairs that will be the
bulk of today's lecture,
to underscore the way in
which these things really
made themselves manifest on
the ground. So Melba Beals
writes very
early in her book,
reflecting back
to when she was,
I believe, twelve years
old. She's walking back
home from school on
the day that Brown v.,
Brown v., Brown versusthe
Board of Education decision
had been announced. And
teachers all--the teachers
told their
students, black teachers,
black students,
"Go straight home.
Don't take any shortcuts.
Just go straight home."
"As I entered the
persimmon field,
I sank deep
into my thoughts,
but a few steps past the
big tree at the front of the
path, I heard a rustling
sound. I stood perfectly
still, looking all around.
I didn't see a soul.
Suddenly, as I came near
to the end of the field,
a man's gravel voice
snatched me from the secret
place in my head.
'You want a ride, girl?'
He didn't sound at all like
anybody I knew.
There it was again,
that stranger's voice
calling out to me. 'Want a
ride?' 'Who is it?' I asked,
barely able to squeeze the
words out. 'I got
candy in the car,
lots of candy.'
I crept forward,
and then I saw
him--a big white man,
even taller than my
father, broad and huge,
like a wrestler.
He was coming
toward me fast.
I turned on my heels
and fled in the opposite
direction, back
the way I had come.
'You'd better come on
and take a ride home,
you hear me girl?'
'No sir!' I yelled,
'No, thank you,'
but he kept coming.
My heart was racing
almost as fast as my feet.
I couldn't hear anything
except for the sound of my
saddle shoes pounding the
ground and the thud of his
feet close behind me.
That's when he started
talking about 'niggers'
wanting to go to school
with his children and how he
wasn't going to
stand for it.
My cries for help drowned
out the sound of his words,
but he laughed and said it
was no use because nobody
would hear me. I was
running as fast as I could.
The lace on my shoe came
untied and my feet got
tangled. As I
hit the ground,
I bit down hard on my
tongue. I felt his strong
hands clutch my back.
I bolted up, struggling to
get away. He pulled me down
and turned me on my back.
I looked up into his face,
looming close above me
like the monster on a movie
screen. I struggled against
him but he was too strong.
He slapped me hard across
the face. I covered my eyes
with my hands and waited
for him to strike me again.
Instead, I felt him
squirm against me,
and then I saw him
taking his pants down.
In my house, private parts
were always kept private. I
couldn't figure out
what he was doing,
but I knew it had to be
bad. I scratched and kicked
and thrashed against him
with every ounce of strength
I could muster. His huge
fists smashed hard against
my face.
I struggled to push him back
and to keep the dark curtain
of unconsciousness
from descending over me.
'I'll show you niggers the
Supreme Court can't run my
life,' he said, as
he--as his hand ripped at my
underpants. A voice inside
my head told me I was going
to die, but there was
nothing I could do about
it. White men
were in charge."
Someone comes to her rescue
within about four or five
seconds of this moment,
before she's actually raped.
One of her classmates she
didn't really know that well
knocks the guy over the head
with a brick and she's able
to escape to safety. Thus
begins her journey towards
becoming one of the Little
Rock Nine. These are the
memories of a twelve year
old. Now I want to set that
stage about systemic
segregation and the ways in
which people were, I
mean from my personal
perspective, were driven
mad by the Supreme--Supreme
Court decision of '54.
To sort of underscore,
for lack of a better phrase,
the intensity of the moment,
a period of profound
ambiguity in this country
and a period of profound
change for blacks as well as
whites, conservatives as
well as liberals. And over
the course of today's
lecture and really Monday's
lecture, we're going to
start canvassing the ways in
which--[student sneezes]
Bless You--the ways in which
this period of, of
incredible instability in
the United States was made,
was felt on many different
levels, in different ways.
So much of today's lecture
is context, for much of the,
for going across the 1940s
up to Brown v.
Board. Now I ended the last
lecture before the midterm
talking about A.
Philip Randolph's March
on Washington Movement,
his bluff with FDR, FDR's
issuing of Executive Order
8802, and the creation of
the FEPC. I was trying to
cram a lot of things into
the lecture. Give me two
minutes to talk about the
FEPC very quickly and move
us into the
1940s. The FEPC,
Fair Employment--Fair
Employment Practices
Commission--Committee, held
high profile hearings in
major cities about
segregation in defense
industry factories. But it
was essentially powerless to
do anything except for
embarrass the companies and
the factories that are,
that are continuing these
practices. Now in terms
of, so literal change,
the FEPC is not doing much,
as it turns out. But again,
since we're
wrestling with--I,
I've been talking about the
tension between the symbolic
and the real. At
the symbolic level,
the FEPC contributes to the,
to blacks' reorientation
away from
notions of, you know,
systems of white patronage.
They have to rely on white
patrons to make ends meet,
but they could turn to the
federal government instead,
but the federal government,
and I started talking about
it with the Black Cabinet
through Marian Anderson's
concert on Easter Sunday,
1939, the federal government
is now standing in,
in complicated
ways, certainly,
but still standing in
and keeping an eye on the
quality of
black life. Well,
here we are in
1941 and 1942,
the U.S.
is now involved in the
Second World War. And as
you'll remember from going
back to the First World War,
as, as the U.S.
is about to get
involved and W.
E.
B.
Du Bois called on African
Americans to close ranks,
but then called on them to
return fighting. You have
black soldiers enlisting in
terrifically large numbers.
You have a lot of the same
kind of troubling dynamics
about training
black soldiers,
their treatment abroad,
positive by foreign troops
and foreign citizens
and negative by U.S.
troops. And you have the
treatment coming home that
is scandalous.
ThePittsburgh Courier,
along with the
Chicago Defender,
the two most important
black newspapers of the day,
the Pittsburgh Courier,
aware that the same dynamic
might repeat
itself, that is,
you know, black soldiers
fighting for citizenship
rights and
being denied them,
in February of 1942 begins
a campaign. It's--It is a
publicity campaign;
it's nothing beyond that,
but it becomes very
popular. It's the Double V
campaign, Double V, two Vs:
that there would be victory
over fascism abroad
and victory over racial
discrimination at home.
This is just like Du Bois's
call, "We return. We return
from fighting. We return
fighting." Okay? But
twenty-three years have
passed. It's the same
call, it's the same agenda.
That's the important thing
to understand. Now Randolph
bluffs FDR into signing
this executive order,
and Randolph realizes he
has an important opportunity
here to make something out
of this bluff and this March
on Washington Movement
becomes an organization,
not just one person
trying to organize a march,
but it actually becomes its
own grassroots organization,
the MO--MOWM. There's no
easy way to say it. The
March on Washington Movement
embodies a certain set of
tactics and they are, for
lack of a better phrase,
racial tactics. Randolph,
as you already know,
was an anti-communist. He
was deeply concerned about
white communists
infiltrating the National
Negro Congress and
when it happened,
he broke from it. And
he saw that the March on
Washington Movement was
a way--by--he kept it
all-black.
I should have said that
first. It was an all-black
movement. He saw by
keeping it all-black,
it would reduce or even
eliminate the chance that
the Communist Party would
infiltrate the organization,
since the Communist Party
was predominantly white.
But Randolph was very clear,
since we're in a time of
war, to go to great ends to
make sure his movement was
not considered black
nationalist. Although it's
all-black, it's not black
nationalist. And Randolph
declares, and I'm quoting
here: "We condemn all
dictatorships, Fascist,
Nazi and Communists.
We are loyal,
patriotic Americans all.
But if American democracy
will not defend its
defenders; if American
democracy will not protect
its protectors; if American
democracy will not give job
to its--jobs to its toilers
because of race or color;
if American democracy will
not issue--insure equality
of opportunity, freedom
and justice to its citizens,
black and white, it is a
hollow mockery and belies
the principles for which
it is supposed to stand."
The March on Washington
Movement is all-black. It
certainly
welcomes white support,
but not within the
organization itself,
and it is profoundly
patriotic as far as its
assertions--as far as its
assertions are concerned.
On the ground, the March on
Washington Movement engaged
in mass,
nonviolent, direct action,
a blend of Gandhi's tactics
and Randolph's experiences
with labor sit-down
strikes. He believed in
small direct
actions, you know,
going into one
region or, you know,
a part of the country with
small and highly symbolic
acts of resistance.
You know it has,
It's sort of a
hodgepodge of org--of,
of, of , of groups
operating under its banner,
doing different things
in different places,
but all embracing
an all-black agenda,
an all-black constituency,
mass nonviolent,
direct action. There's
another group that's founded
in 1942, a year after
the March on Washington
Movement, that embraced this
secular--that embraced a
different agenda from
the March on Washington--a
different organizing
agenda, pardon me,
from the March on
Washington Movement. It was
interracial civil rights
organization called the
Congress on
Racial Equality, CORE,
Congress on Racial Equality,
an off-shoot of the pacifist
Fellowship of
Reconciliation.
CORE was founded in 1942.
Its director was James
Farmer, and one of the
principal organizers was a
man, was a man
named Bayard Rustin,
someone we'll hear more
about in the next couple of
weeks. CORE and the March
on Washington Movement were
two of the main
groups operating in,
in the 1940s to educate
blacks to use nonviolent
direct action. So they
shared that strategic
logic. CORE
was interracial;
March on Washington Movement
was all-black. The March on
Washington Movement built
its base on the Brotherhood
of Sleeping Car
Porters and Maids Union,
using Randolph's
organizing skills,
and really tried to reach
out to lower-class blacks as
well. CORE was
significantly smaller than
March on
Washington Movement,
and it was focused on
essentially the demographic
you represent:
college-aged student,
highly
educated, interracial,
and essentially elitist.
CORE's mission statement
says that it has one
purpose: to eliminate racial
discrimination, and it
has one method: interracial
nonviolent, direct
action. And of course,
style was to
test, to negotiate,
to confer and then
to sit-in. Test,
negotiate, confer, and
sit-in.Now I'm going to
move away from these two
groups rather quickly,
but I wanted you to
understand these different
organizing logics, although
they're sharing the same
strategic mode of
engagement. Understand
they're happening in
the 1940s as well,
because as I hope to make
clear through this lecture
and through much of the next
couple of weeks' lectures,
it's very critical you start
to re-periodize the civil
rights movement. The
kinds of things that I just
mentioned here, I hope that
you will recognize from your
basic high school
American History class,
talking about the
civil rights movement,
that famous movement
between '54 and '68,
at the most, okay?
The strategies of,
of, of, sort of the high
theater of the civil rights
movement roots go back
to the 1940s and beyond,
with direct
corrections and a,
a direct
lineage of, of sorts,
of resistance.
You need to understand this;
it's rather important. Now
what's happening in the
1940s? What's the scene in
which the March on
Washington Movement and CORE
are operating? The country
is in transition. It's in
war. As I
already mentioned,
the Great Migration
happening in the first two
decades of the twentieth
century. There's another
migration happening now that
dwarfs the Great Migration,
a migration of
African Americans,
many of whom are following
defense industry jobs out
West and in the
North. Essentially,
the black population you
know of in Los Angeles is
there because of, of defense
industry jobs and factory
jobs during this period of
time. This is the moment,
over the next decade, when
African Americans move from
being predominantly a rural
population--I think it's
about forty percent at
that point--to over fifty or
fifty-five percent urban.
So it's a transition,
profound transition,
for African Americans,
as far as demographics are
concerned. Now with this
migration, like the
first Great Migration,
you have crisis,
pressure for housing,
cultural styles, political
battlefields. 1943 is a
spectacular year for
crisis. You have race riots
happening in the summer of
'43 in forty-seven different
cities. One of the most
famous is the Zoot Suit
Riots in Los Angeles, which
involved not blacks in this
case, but Mexicans,
and Mexican Americans,
and white Navy--I think it's
Navy. I'm pretty sure it's
Navy--members of the Navy
attacking Los Angelinos who
happened to be Mexican, for
straying across racial and
social lines. The worst
riot happens in Detroit,
a mere ten days before a
March on Washington Movement
convention in
Chicago. The riot,
in all of its violence,
colored the March on
Washington Movement in
Chicago--convention in
Chicago, and so militant
race leadership is seen as
too provocative and
un-American. And really,
people can deny the fact
that blacks actually were
beginning to get jobs
in these factories,
because factories were so
desperate for workers. You
have migration,
racial violence,
a country at war, the
March on Washington Movement
agitating, making some
headway as far as its
long-term goals, but also
having a narrower range in
which it could
operate, because,
you know, appearing
un-American is the last
thing you want to do at
this moment in time. It's
something that Randolph
himself articulates.
Meanwhile, membership
in the NAACP skyrockets,
as the
organiza--organization
appears to be a more
moderate and reasonable
location for civil rights
agitation than the all-black
March on
Washington Movement,
even though it's making,
it's a pro-American stance,
and more moderate than this
upstart CORE that people
don't really know what to
make of yet. So you have
now, by the mid-1940s,
the NAACP becoming,
turning into this
moderate organization,
by outward appearances,
where it was on the edge,
sort of the avant
garde, when it was founded,
and for the first
decade, decade,
two decades of its
existence. Things are
shifting. Things shift
fundamentally in 1944 in a
legal case, Smith v.
Allwright, that
outlaws the white,
outlaws the white-only
primary. And I have to
apologize. I have to go
really quickly through a lot
of these things, because
I lost a lecture by the
midterm, so I'm not going to
get into the details. But
in the Smith v.
Allwrightcase, the
white, white primaries,
white primaries
are now outlawed,
and now liberal
groups, broadly defined,
start going after a whole
set of different means of
exclusion, of preserving,
essentially an all-white
vote. Groups start going
after literacy tests that
were, that were at
the point of absurdity,
where a registrar could
actually ask somebody,
"How many bubbles are
there in a bar of soap?"
as a way to exclude them.
People knew they had to act
in terms of trying to
expand the right to vote,
or access to the
ballot box, ballot box,
by just looking at
Mississippi. In
Mississippi, you have
over three hundred and fifty
thousand blacks who are
eligible to register,
register to vote.
Mississippi has a huge black
population. And of that
three hundred and fifty
thousand, only twenty-five
hundred manage to vote in
1946. It's an
all-white vote,
because of all the various
ways in which Mississippi
registrars and voters are
being told to eliminate the
black vote.
In fact, very famously,
Senator Bilbo from,
from Mississippi, who
was a virulent racist,
would go around organizing
registrars of voters
of--before actual
election night,
telling them all these
different ways in which you
can eliminate
the black vote,
and said, you know, "If
worst comes to worst,
you all know the most
effective strategy is the
night before the election,
and you know what I mean,
I mean essentially calling
for them to rally the Klan
to eliminate
black vote. Again,
the country's in--under
incredible stress because of
these transitions going on.
Between '46 and '48 at the
presidential level, some
more radical changes are
happening. FDR had died in
office already. Now Harry
Truman is the President,
and he's fighting for his
political life. The
Democratic Party's on the
verge of being split.
Recognizing that there's
incredible dissension
amongst the Democratic
ranks, Southern Democrats
are very unhappy with the
trends in what's
happening in the country,
supported by the
federal government,
that entity that blacks saw
as a place of salvation.
Truman doesn't
know what to do,
and so he actually lets--he
sort of throws a bone to his
antagonists in the
Democratic Party and lets
Congress kill the FEPC.
So now there's no more
publicity campaign
machine to sort of embarrass
factories into employing
African Americans and
practicing
non-discrimination
policies. Truman lets
Congress kill the FEPC but
knows he needs the black
vote to win election. It
was clear when FDR
got elected in 1944,
it was clear that the black
vote is what brought him,
got him into office, and
Truman can't lose it. So
Truman raises the stakes,
after killing the FEPC,
and appoints a distinguished
panel to serve as the
President's
Commission on Civil Rights,
which would recommend over
time more adequate means and
procedures for the
protection of civil rights
for U.S.
citizens.
In October '47
it issues its,
its report, called "To
Secure These Rights,
a landmark document. "To
Secure These Rights" defined
the nation's civil
rights agenda for the next
generation. The commission
noted the many restrictions
on blacks and urged
that each person,
regardless of race,
color, or national origin,
should have access to equal
opportunity in securing
education, decent housing,
and jobs. Among its
proposals, the commission
suggested anti-lynching and
anti-poll tax laws,
a permanent FEPC,
and
strengthen--strengthening
the Civil Rights Division of
the Department of Justice.
The commission went
much further than Southern
Democrats ever imagined
they would dare to go,
further than Truman thought
they would actually go. But
he called this commission
together and so he had to
face a choice, what to
do. So in February of 1948,
Truman rolls the dice and
calls for the implementation
of the Commission's
recommendations.
Southerners immediately
threaten a filibuster and
Truman, unable to secure
support from Congress or
action from Congress,
moves ahead using executive
authority. And
among other things,
he bolsters the Civil Rights
Division at the Department
of Justice, appoints the
first black judge to the
federal bench, names several
other blacks to high-ranking
administrative positions,
and most important,
on July 26th of 1948, he
issued the executive order
abolishing segregation in
the armed forces and ordered
full integration of all
the services. The executive
orders that grow out of this
array of changes are 9980,
nine-nine-eight-zero,
establishing fair employment
practices in the
federal government,
and the next
one immediately,
so you can see
he's going on a tear,
Executive Order 9981
establishes the President's
Committee on Equality of
Treatment and Opportunity in
the Armed Forces, the
decree that leads to the
desegregation order to
the military. Now it's the
order. The military
takes its sweet old time
desegregating, but the
order's issued in 1948,
growing out of
this--Truman's political
move to sort of clarify
the mess of the Democratic
Party, make it known to
African Americans that he
was going to support them,
the Democratic Party would
support them. But was it
enough? Henry Wallace,
who had been a former
Vice President of FDR,
before he got booted, very
progressive and challenges
Truman from the left.
The real challenge
comes from the right,
within the Democratic Party,
let me be clear. Truman's
support for a strong civil
rights platform for the
Democratic, Democratic
convention that was coming
up is opposed by
conservative Democrats. And
they say, "If you bring this
platform to the convention
floor, we will leave."
Truman brought the platform
to the convention floor and
conservative Democrats from
Southern states bolt and
form what is popularly known
as the Dixiecrat Party,
with Strom Thurmond as its
presidential candidate. The
Democratic Party is split
and it's quite unclear
what's going to happen.
Now, what happens is that
Truman wins by a hair's
breath, and again,
without black support,
he never would have been
elected to a full term as
President. Now that's
what's happening on sort of
the high political stage
throughout the 1940s. Let
me quickly canvass
what's happening,
it's still
politics of course,
but in the legal
arena, over this period,
to help you understand
another element of this,
of this shift that's
happening in the country on
these issues. And what I
want to give you is the
legal history of Brown v.
Board of Education. That's
where this is heading up
to. The legal history
begins at Howard University
Law School. I already
mentioned before the
National--the New
Negro Alliance,
excuse me, formed in
1933, relied upon law school
students and law professors
at Howard University Law
School to argue its case
that eventually becomes a
Supreme Court decision in
1930--I forgot my notes.
I'll just guess '37, I'm
blanking right now. But the
battle begins at Howard
University Law School.
Excuse me, I've lost
track for a second.
There we go.
Charles Houston,
the attorney who also
spearheads its citizens
campaign for Marian
Anderson's concert,
he's brought in to head
up the law school in the
late-1920s, to bring it up
to fully accredited status.
He starts hiring professors
of law. Some of the great
legal jurists of the next
twenty and thirty years,
forty years would actually
start at Howard University
Law School as professors,
and they would train that
first cadre of civil
rights attorneys. In fact,
the first civil rights law
class in the country was
taught at Howard during this
period. The most famous
student during
the period, this,
this early-1930s, is
Thurgood Marshall. Thurgood
Marshall, a
native of Maryland,
wanted to go to the
University of Maryland
School of Law,
but by practice,
blacks were not admitted, so
he had to go to--he ended up
going to Howard University.
And at that very small law
school with some
very intense faculty,
he goes through sort of a
boot camp for several years,
and comes out with the
kind of legalized training,
with special attention
to civil rights cases.
Marshall scores his first
major court victory along
these lines in 1935, in a
case called Murray versus
Pearson.
In this case, a guy
named Donald Murray was not
allowed to enter the
University of Maryland
because he was
black. Raymond Pearson,
the president of the
University of Maryland--so
it's the student versus the
president as far as naming
conventions, Murray versus
Pearson--said that Murray
could obtain separate
but equal training at the
Princess Anne Academy, also
in the state of Maryland.
However, the Princess
Anne Academy did not offer a
legal degree, which is what
Murray was actually trying
to obtain.
Making a long story short,
Marshall and his mentor,
now increasingly
colleague, Charles Houston,
who's now the head of the
Legal Defense Fund at NAACP,
argue the case up to the
Supreme Court. And the
court declares that the
University of Maryland,
because it did not have a
separate and equal facility
for teaching law, had
to let Murray in. Okay,
that's 1935. Based on
the success of that case,
Houston brings Marshall over
to the NAACP and they start
traveling from southern
courthouse to southern
courthouse to
southern courthouse,
filing law--lawsuits
for black students and
teachers. In 1938, in
the case--these are Supreme
Court cases by
the way--Gaines v.
Canada. Lloyd Gaines is the
plaintiff and Canada--who
is, I'm missing
the first name here.
It's the last name of the
registrar of the University
of Missouri. So the
case is called Gaines v.
Canada. It's a student
versus the registrar of the
University of Missouri.
The University of Missouri
refused to
admit Lloyd Gaines,
African American, to its law
school because the school
was only for whites. It was
common in Missouri for the
state to send black students
to neighboring states for
courses of study not
offered by Missouri's black
schools. Since Missouri
did not have a separate but
equal law school for blacks,
the Supreme Court declares
that Gaines had to be
allowed to attend the
University of Missouri
Law School. So you have in
Murray v.
Pearson, there's no separate
institution offering a law
degree in Maryland,
so you have to let,
admit Murray into the
school of law. In Gaines v.
Canada,
University of Missouri,
the idea of shipping a
student out of state--which
was not just a Missouri
practice by the way. A lot
of southern students--states
did this--was ruled
unconstitutional. The state
had to provide state-funded
separate but equal
legal facility. Now,
I mean, one
might ask, why's,
why would a state
even, you know,
provide these fellowships,
scholarships to get the
students educated in law
school if not in their own
state? The thinking was,
you got them out of the
state, they would stay out
of the state. So the South
was trying to
export black legal,
potential legal talent to
northern places mainly. To
get that "problem"
out of their state,
they'd pay for them to
leave. The Supreme Court
says, "Can't do
it." That's 1938,
if I didn't mention that.
Houston and Marshall keep
plugging away,
filing the lawsuits,
poking at the
system. In 1946,
they take on the case of a
woman named Ada Sipuel. In
'46, Sipuel had applied to
the University of Oklahoma
Law School and was denied
because of race. And in
1948, the Supreme Court
finally rules that Oklahoma
had to provide instruction
for blacks equal to that of
whites. So this is now--not
following--they're not
breaking new ground
here. They're following a
precedent that was
there in the Donald v.
Murray, bounded by Gaines v.
Canada, say you can't ship
her out some place else. So
Oklahoma says, "All right,
well we're going to comply.
We're not going to admit
her to our law school,
to the white law school.
We'll build a law school for
her." And so in a few
months' time the state of
Oklahoma creates the
Langston University School
of Law, located at
the state capital,
thus requiring further
litigation to demonstrate
that the law school was
inferior to the University
of Oklahoma's law
school. I mean,
the lawyers
were, were claiming,
"You cannot build a law
school in a few months,
and it really was just
done in a few months,
"designed to educate blacks
in the state and suggest
that it's even near equal
to what the University of
Oklahoma's already
established law school
provides." They
don't have the resources,
they don't have the access,
they don't have the training
available to them. So
further litigation ensues
and in 1949, Oklahoma,
the University of Oklahoma
decides to admit Sipuel,
thus breaking the color line
for the School of Law there.
Sipuel becomes not just
the first black woman,
or black, to integrate
in the University of
Oklahom--Oklahoma
Law School,
she's the first black woman
to attend an all-white law
school in the entire South.
The law school admits here
and gives her a
special chair. That's nice,
it seems, right? Well, the
chair is marked "colored"
and it's roped off from the
rest of the class. She's in
the same classroom but in a
roped off section of one.
Now as it happens, her
classmates and teachers
actually welcome her
into the classroom. The
resistance is coming
from someplace else,
institutionally or
governmentally. Stories
abound, and
Sipuel is--would,
would support this, that
students shared their notes
with her, studied with
her, helped her catch up on
material if she happened to
miss some of it. Sipuel had
to eat in a
separate section of the,
of a separate and chained
off and guarded section in
the law school cafeteria,
and white students would
crawl under the chain and
eat with her when the guards
weren't around. Her
law student tuition are
supported by hundreds
of small donations and,
she would recount later, she
believed she owed it to all
those who supported her that
she had to ser--that she had
to make it. Now actually,
if you look up on the
website, and I imagine one
or two might do it right
now, even though
I hope you don't,
the University of
Oklahom--Oklahoma Law School
is named for Ada Sipuel now.
This is also a generational
change of another kind of
order.
In any event, the important
thing about all these
different cases, these three
sort of landmark cases,
they shared some things in
common. They're all about
law schools. They're
all about law schools.
Marshall and Houston
believed that they had to
find test cases that would
create the greatest chance
of sympathy from judges
and eventually Supreme Court
justices.
And so they thought by
bringing to their attention,
to the judges' attention,
people who wanted to be like
them, study the law, and
people who--and this is
important, and I'll speak
more about it on Monday--who
were astonishingly good
students. They had to be
perfect students.
By bringing incredible
students in front of them
who are trying to
become lawyers,
these judges
might be, you know,
have thought, "Well,
gosh, this really is a silly
system. We need to
find some other way,
other way around it." So
that's one part about it.
It's just about, it's
just about access to law
schools. Now
what it's also,
and probably even
more important--not even
probably--definitely more
important about these law
school, these cases,
these legal cases,
is that none of them
challenged Plessy v.
Ferguson. All of them are
articulated upon the grounds
of, there is no
separate but equal,
equal institution for these
black plaintiffs to attend.
In Maryland, in
Missouri, in Oklahoma,
in each of those cases,
they're saying there's no
separate but equal
institution. Oklahoma tried
making one. It wasn't equal
enough. It was separate but
not equal. So these--this
is a nice and slow and
gentle, I mean
according to them,
approach to try to break
down segregation in higher
education. Based on the
success they're meeting with
the law schools, they
start going after graduate
schools. So professional
schools into graduate
schools, and then
they start--I mean,
and basically the writing is
now on the wall. People see
this.
They realize the trajectory
of these attorneys is
heading sort of
downward in a sense,
hierarchically, and the next
battlefield is going to be
secondary and primary
schools. Southern states
recognize this and
feverishly start trying to
improve black schools, which
were horrible. I mean the,
the statistics are kind of
shocking about how poorly
funded these
schools were, you know,
only used textbooks, no
transportation. Southern
states try--start
trying pouring,
pouring money
into these schools,
trying to improve them, so
they could actually survive
a test of separate but
equal. But they're so bad,
they can't catch
up. So the attorneys,
NAACP attorneys, start
focusing now on elementary
and secondary schools
and challenging the very
principle of segregation in
education--that seg--that
segregation on racial lines
was unconstitutional. They,
as they're going around
setting up these test cases,
there are five cases all
happening at the same time
that rise to the
Supreme Court's attention,
and the Supreme--Supreme
Court bundles them
together. There are
cases in South Carolina,
Virginia, Kansas, Delaware,
and the District of
Columbia. They bundle
them together under Brown,
the father of two girls
integrating--trying to
integrate schools in Topeka,
Kansas. But that's--this is
one case representing many
other cases. The attorney
general of the United States
actually calls for the end
of segregation, but the
reasoning is revealing. He
wrote that, "Racial
discrimination furnishes
grist for the Communist
propaganda mills and it
raises doubt even among
friendly nations as to the
intensity of our devotion
to the Democratic faith."
He's not
talking about, "Hey,
we need to educate our
citizens." It's like,
"This looks bad on the
international scene. It's
embarrassing and it's, it's
affecting negatively our
potential to make change
around the world." Cutting
to the chase, Brown versus
the Board of Education makes
it to the Supreme Court, and
the ruling is offered in May
of 1954. Earl Warren,
the very new Chief Justice,
writes the opinion for a
unanimous court that says,
"The separate educational
facilities is in--inherently
unequal.
Therefore, we hold that
the plaintiffs and others
similarly situated for
whom the actions have been
brought up (brought, I mean,
this is the bundling) are,
by reason of the
segregation complained of,
deprived of the equal
protection of the laws
guaranteed by the
Fourteenth Amendment."
Separation of the races
and facilities is inherently
unequal, based on equal
protection clause in the
Fourteenth Amendment.
Now, very quickly,
a few words about Earl
Warren himself because it's
actually fascinating.
He's a--while the,
while these cases are
being bundled and brought up
through the, the system,
he's not the Chief Justice.
He's appointed that
position--He's not even on
the Supreme Court. He's
appointed to that position
after the Chief
Justice, Fred Vinson,
dies. Someone,
jurists, legal,
legal historians think it
was probably going to go
against Brown. Eisenhower,
now the President of the
United States, appoints
what others thought a mere
politician to
the Supreme Court,
thus angering other
associate justices who
thought they were going to
be the next Chief Justice.
And Warren would actually
go on to become a great
mediator on the court, using
his political skills. And
becomes on-- becomes a
great civil rights jurist,
someone Eisenhower would
call "the greatest mistake
of his presidency,"
appointing Warren to the
Supreme Court. Now Warren
himself did not have a
sterling civil
liberties record. In fact,
it was pretty horrible.
When he was the attorney
general of
California in 1942,
he led the move to detain
and then inter Japanese
Americans. And as he told
a conference of his fellow
governors in 1943, his
first year as governor of
California,"If the
Japs are released,
no one will be able to tell
the saboteur from any other
Jap. We're now producing
approximately half of the
ships and airplanes of
the country on the Pacific
Coast. To cripple these
industries or the facilities
that serve them would be a
bloody--a body blow to the
war effort. We don't
want to have a second Pearl
Harbor in California. We
don't propose to have the
Japs back in California
during this war if there is
any lawful means
of preventing it."
This is one of the
great civil rights justices
speaking before he was
elevated to that position.
So people doing some
basic psychoanalysis,
armchair psychoanalysis,
saying Warren is trying--I
mean is horrified in
retrospect over what he did
in a moment of war, what he
felt was right at the time,
to deny citizenship
rights to so many people,
and was trying to
sort of cleanse himself.
Now there's much more to
be said about Brown v.
Board of Education, the
legal court case. But this
part is important to know,
in the sense that Warren
comes in out of the blue.
It probably changes the
future of the decision.
The, the--If you look at
justices' opinions leading
up to Brown, it seemed at
best there might be a split
in the court,
if not a denial,
but Warren said, "No, we
are going to be active,
essentially, and it
must be unanimous,
and he basically browbeat
the associate justices to
line up behind him to offer
this ruling. A watershed
moment, thus
closing the door on the
constitutionality of
separate but equal,
articulated in Plessy v.
Ferguson at the end of the
nineteenth century. Now the
Supreme Court says that
this is unconstitutional,
segregation in,
in, in education,
but how are you going to
change it? This is probably
one of the most--This may be
the most cruel but important
part of Brown v.
Board of Education, is that
it's remanded back to local
districts to figure out
the best play--best way to
desegregate the
schools. South Carolina,
Georgia, Mississippi
governors threaten to
abolish public schools as a
result. "We'll just close
all the damn
public schools,
because the Supreme Court
is only talking about public
places of accommodation.
A year after Brown is
articulated, it comes back
with what people call Brown
II, when the Supreme Court
sends these cases back to
the local, local--sends the
cases back to the courts of
origins and in
deference to local customs,
and familiarity, says that
these things should proceed
with "all deliberate
speed." One of these
wonderfully vague,
damningly vague,
Supreme Court edicts.
All deliberate speed.Many
people thought, "like really
quickly!" Other people
thought, "Let's deliberate
for a long time." Speed,
after all, is really quite
relative. There are many
other immediate
ramifications or responses
to Brown v.
Board and its ruling in 1954
and '55. You--We began the
lecture with one
of them, with Anna,
excuse me, Melba Beals as
a young girl about to be
raped, because the Supreme
Court had enraged this white
father, that it was going
to change the way the world
looked for him. We'll talk
more about other ways of
resistance and high
political theater and Gothic
violence in the
wake of Brown v.
Board when we pick up
on Monday. Thank you.